hey guys what's up every saturday i sit
down with will clemente from blockwear
but unfortunately couldn't join us this
week so i thought what would be really
interesting was to go through the recent
blockwear 2021
update that they put out it's a great
great great piece of information and i
highly suggest you go and you read it
they went through everything from q1 to
q2 to q3 to q4 and then also included a
2022 market outlook so i'm gonna go
through the charts that they included in
that 2022 market outlook and then i
suggest that you go back and you read
the rest of what they included in this
report so first let's start with the
actual price of bitcoin what we saw
obviously throughout the year was that
bitcoin's price rose and then it fell in
the summer and then it came flying back
and now we're sitting somewhere in the
mid 40 thousands and so of course
there's a confirmation of the immediate
term trend and it's likely to play out
early into the first quarter of 2022
according to will and the team and this
is signified by bitcoin either breaking
out above 53 000 or below 42 000 and so
ultimately i think that is what we're
watching for from a price standpoint is
are we going to see over 53 or under 42
but price is obviously not the only
thing worth paying attention to in this
market going into the new year there's
lots of other things you can call them
fundamentals if you will that you should
be paying attention to first we've got a
chart that looks at the lightning
network itself this is the layer 2 built
on top of bitcoin and what you can see
is that the network capacity according
to the seven-day moving average has been
absolutely exploding throughout 2021.
and so the expectation from blockware is
that they expect to see continued growth
of the lightning network and expand the
monetary properties of bitcoin from
being a solely a store of value to being
an effective medium exchange as well the
lightning network is a big big piece of
that so i tend to agree with them that
that is what we should expect to happen
we obviously right now are sitting right
around an all-time high of the lightning
network network capacity and so
ultimately there's no reason in my
opinion why that trend won't simply
continue into the new year
if we then go ahead and we look we now
have the balance on exchanges across all
exchanges on the crypto industry what we
see here is that bitcoin was coming on
two exchanges all the way through 2017
2018 2019 and into 2020. but we got a
peak in 2020 of the bitcoin that was
actually sitting on these centralized
exchanges and since about mid 2020 that
balance has been going down over time
and so ultimately according to what
blockwear and we'll see there they are
expecting to see continued depletion of
centralized bitcoin exchange reserves as
institutional market participants
seek to take custody of the digital
assets and increase growth of bitcoin
collateralized loans so ultimately their
thought process is that the number of
bitcoins sitting on these exchanges is
going to go down over time some of
that's because people want to take
custody of their assets some of it's
also because they want to take it off
the exchange and use it for loans and
some of it frankly may just be that
people don't want to sell and so leaving
it on this exchange just has higher risk
and they simply want to just hold on to
it themselves whatever the reason i tend
to agree that yes the number of bitcoin
on the exchange is likely to go down
over long periods of time over 6 12 18
24 months so keep an eye on this because
ultimately people can't sell bitcoin if
it's not sitting on exchanges if we then
go and look it's not just about spot
bitcoin though obviously the interest in
the
uh derivatives market is really
important so we've got the options open
interest here and what we can see is
that that seven day moving average
throughout 2020 under the earliest parts
of 2021 there was massive increase in
the options open interest across all the
exchanges and throughout 2021 we've seen
ups and downs of that open interest and
we've pretty much ended about right
where we started which is pretty
interesting to see according to the team
over at blockwear what they've said is
that with the institutionalization of
the bitcoin market they expect to see
substantial growth in the options market
as active managers seek to hedge harvest
volatility and perform other more exotic
option strategies that take advantage of
the inefficiencies in the bitcoin market
it's pretty damn cool to see that now
bitcoin is not just some asset for
individuals on the internet or random
strangers who are buying it they're
simply holding it there's a true
financial market around this there's all
kinds of different financial assets
there's all sorts of different
opportunities that people can go ahead
and leverage and options is a huge piece
of that so it will likely become more
and more popular over time one of that's
just a function of more people joining
the market another is that there's
actually more types of options available
and then lastly is that some of the
people who are into bitcoin previously
but knew nothing about options are also
going to become more educated on this
type of investing as well
if we then go and we look at the actual
bitcoin issuance so the next thing in
this report they can see that however
there is one thing for sure regardless
of what you think's gonna happen in the
lightning network regardless of what you
think is gonna happen in terms of
options interest or spot market the
supply issuance won't change and bitcoin
will keep pumping out blocks regularly
every 10 minutes and so ultimately what
this chart here is showing us is that
that issuance in orange goes down and is
very very predictable we know exactly
900 bitcoin are going to come into the
market every single day day after day
after day throughout 2022. and so what
you can see is the relationship here to
the price is something that you would
continue to expect bitcoin's issuance
goes down price goes up it's a finite
asset as demand increases for an asset
that becomes scarcer and scarcer the us
dollar price has to move to accommodate
everyone that's what we've seen over the
historical movements of both issuance
and price and that is what we should
expect to continue to see going into
2022. and then ultimately hash rate
hashrate was one of the big stories i
believe of 2021. obviously in may of
2021 we saw china go ahead and ban
mining in the country they had about 60
of all bitcoin mining within their
borders at the time and so hash rate
dropped in some cases uh it looks like
it dropped almost 50 percent or so and
then ultimately came roaring back to
close out the year hitting another
all-time high and so the team over at
blockwear will and friends wrote
bitcoin's hash rate will continue to
grow throughout 2022 as more and more
miners join the network the top public
miners alone are expected to bring on
56.5
ehs by the end of the year many large
asic orders have already been purchased
from bitmain and the new generation
machines will continue to be delivered
throughout 2022 as long as the price of
bitcoin doesn't have a sharp crash these
new machines will likely be pulling in
revenue significantly higher than their
operating expenses so i tend to agree as
well that there will be more and more
bitcoin miners joining the network
hashrate will continue and i think that
we will see multiple new all-time highs
in hash rate throughout 2022. what's
very interesting to me and this is my
personal opinion not included in the
report that they provided is that the
big story that we are watching or some
of the big stories is one is the bull
market going to be longer than usual
historically bull markets in the bitcoin
uh ecosystem have been about 18 months
after the last having but now what we've
seen is we've now been about 18 months
since the last halving and there's a lot
of people who still think the bull
market is going to continue if that
occurs going into q1 or q2 of 2022 i
think a lot of people will start to buy
into the idea that the bull market is
actually going to get longer and longer
as we get more and more adoption that
would make sense on top of that there's
another storyline around bitcoin and the
10-year treasury yield obviously people
think that that treasury yield is
inversely related to all sorts of risk
assets so you would expect as the
interest rates or treasury yields go up
then all of a sudden tech stocks and
other risk on assets would sell off
inverse relationship but there are a
number of weeks in the month of december
where the bitcoin price has been
tracking almost lockstep with the
10-year treasury yield and so if that
was to continue into 2022 and we
actually saw interest rates get moved up
and the yields go up could bitcoin's
price go up as well that in my opinion
would be a narrative violation many
people expect that bitcoin would sell
off if interest rates rise but in some
crazy way maybe that's not the case so
that's something to watch i don't know
what the answer is but that's something
that i'm watching going into the new
year a third theme that i'm thinking
about going into the new year is that
there is a brain drain on legacy wall
street and silicon valley there are tons
and tons of talented people both young
and older that are leaving their legacy
jobs at corporations or startups and
saying i want to go to the frontier i
want to go where the innovation is
happening i want to go where the
experimentation is occurring and they
are leaving in droves to go into the
bitcoin and crypto market and so that
brain drain of both legacy tech and
finance i think is only going to
accelerate some of those legacy
corporations will get into the crypto
industry and they'll start adopting some
of these technologies and they will try
to keep the talent that way but others
are simply going to throw up their hands
and say we can't pay these people enough
we can't keep them here so we're just
gonna have to lose them but the brain
drain will only accelerate going into
the new year
and then lastly the other thing that i'm
paying attention to and i'm making sure
that i'm working on in terms of
understanding what's happening is
regulation obviously something like
bitcoin has gotten the seal of approval
from the sec the cftc and other
regulatory bodies around the world it's
not a security and it's being treated
that way by both the market and also
corporations that support it in various
ways but there's a lot of questions
about other types of assets but other
types of smart contract platforms or
other types of technology that's been
built in the industry what are
regulators going to say about that are
they legal are they not legal are they
legal within certain variations to the
existing rules do only the existing
rules apply with no variations how do
you enforce the rules when it comes to
things that have decentralization you
can't actually put a smart contract in
jail you can't find it in some cases you
can't even shut it down what do you do
to actually enforce the rules once
you've decided on the rules these are
all big questions going into 2022 that i
don't have the answers to the regulators
don't have the answers to the
multiple market participants don't have
the answers to and neither do the
lawyers everyone is trying to figure it
out in real time that's part of the
excitement but it's also part of the
sober view of making sure that you're
paying attention to what regulation is
happening in the industry so ultimately
2021 was a great year bitcoin's up 65 or
so for the year and i think there's a
lot of people who previously knew
nothing about bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies or other various assets
in the industry now they're
participating now they're buying and
selling the assets they're holding them
they're building technology they're
building companies and projects and i
think that the more smart people the
more capital we can get into the
industry the better and so if 2021 was a
great year i expect 2022 to be an even
better one because now we have the
tailwinds there's intellectual capital
there's financial capital and ultimately
at the frontier that's where people
dream it's where people dream of
building a better world that's where
people dream of actually changing the
world i think that's exactly what's
happening in this industry so it's
exciting it's fun i think 2022 is going
to be the best one yet so i'll see you
guys in the new year hope that you guys
enjoyed this little preview both of what
i think is going to happen but also will
clemente the blockwear team and their
report i highly suggest you go and you
go grab that read through what they saw
happening in q1 q2 q3 and q4 of 2021.
2022 is gonna be a fun one and i can't
wait to see you there